Ils ont l'envie de rejouer la Coupe d'Europe
en 2020.
Ca fait toujours plaisir de faire partie d'un
projet et de l'amener au bout.
J'ai 30 ans, je pense pouvoir apporter beaucoup
d'expérience.
C'est pour ça que je suis revenue.
Question : Le fait d'être une des pierres
angulaires de ce nouveau projet, de repartir
vers les sommets, est-ce que c'est ça qui
a motivé votre décision ?
A partir de quel moment vous avez entamé
les discussions avec le club ?
Le fait que le club veuille rejouer une coupe
d'Europe ?
Oui forcément, quand un club vous dit qu'il
veut redevenir européen dans les années
proches, oui ça me donne envie.
Je ne serai pas repartie dans un club qui
n'aurait pas cet objectif là.
Et qui n'a pas les moyens surtout, parce que
Fleury a carrément les moyens sportifs pour
faire les Coupes d'Europe, la Coupe d'Europe
dans 2 ans.